this is the boat to where climate
activists Greta tomb Berg will be cooped
up for at least two weeks on Tuesday she
went to familiarize herself with the
vessel her dilemma had been how to get
to New York without increasing her
carbon footprint this yacht she hopes is
the answer
last week she admitted the journey would
not be easy
I have not sailed before I get so I but
I am going to to go there now and to try
to just sort of get basic lessons and
how how to what to do and what not to do
before setting sail skipper boris
hermann brief tune berg and her father
who will accompany her on possible
problems including the weather this trip
will be massively challenging for
greater and for all of us and and I hope
we will be able to find a route through
the weather that is not too rough so we
can make our route a bit longer to sail
around strong winds that's not always
possible so we have discussed this we
have she tries to mentally prepare for
that the weather will not be the only
challenge the 80-foot yacht is designed
for speed rather than luxury so the
amenities such as the sleeping quarters
are basic at best and there is no toilet
or shower but the vessel is fitted with
solar panels and the electricity onboard
is produced by underwater turbines this
means to mug is likely to achieve her
goal of making the long journey across
the Atlantic with zero carbon emissions
you